As one of the young breakthrough stars of
the Harry Potter film franchise, Tom Felton
grew up in front of the whole world, right
alongside his character, the villainous Draco
Malfoy.
He may not have been a member of the heroic
trinity in the series, but among Potter fans,
Felton's name became just about as well-known
as his co-stars.
So, it seemed logical that he'd be among those
who'd slither in to the A-list after the series
came to an end in 2011.
Unlike some of the others, though, Felton
has since struggled to shed his status as
an alumnus of Hogwarts, which means his career
outside of the World of Witchcraft and Wizardry
has been anything but magical.
Whereas Daniel Radcliffe has become something
of an indie sensation and Emma Watson headlined
an entirely different blockbuster with curses
and castles, Tom Felton hasn't been able to
ride his Nimbus 2000 to the top of the Hollywood
ladder just yet.
Let's take a look at some of the reasons Hollywood
won't cast him anymore.
Conflicted feelings
Starring in an eight-film mega-movie franchise
might seem like the opportunity of a lifetime
for any actor, but Tom Felton didn't cherish
the experience of being an overnight cinematic
success story as much as others might.
Before the final film Deathly Hallows, Part
2 hit theaters, he told the Daily Mail that
he looked forward to the "freedom" of not
starring in the films anymore, saying:
"One thing that people keep on saying to me
is that the wealth and the fame must have
made up for missing out on my childhood.
But the idea of money, putting a price on
your childhood, is ridiculous.
To me, fame is not a positive thing.
The idea of being famous is a lot better than
the reality.
It's fantastic when you go to premieres and
people cheer you, but it's not real."
Considering most of those fans who were cheering
him on at those very premieres were the ones
he'd need to see his next movies, those words
may have come back to bite him harder than
Nagini.
A career left turn
After Harry Potter, Daniel Radcliffe decided
to give the Broadway circuit and small-budget
films a whirl.
And Emma Watson went to college, became a
beauty brand ambassador, and left Hermione
behind with films like The Bling Ring and
This Is the End.
"I'm not f---ing around!"
Meanwhile, Tom Felton's first big post-Potter
move was to rap.
Yes, rap.
In 2011, Felton revealed that he'd scored
a recording deal with an independent label
to produce some hip-hop music, saying:
"I was thinking of doing some N-Dubz-style
stuff.
I am looking to get into the grime rap UK
scene."
Felton added that he intended to "change [his]
image," and although that public persona overhaul
never seemed to pan out, some of his music
has made way to the public sphere.
However, despite a few EP releases and a moderate
amount of viral attention on YouTube, his
music has hardly been successful enough to
qualify as a new career path.
Too familiar
His emcee effort might've at least been a
change of pace, but Felton's next big screen
adventure was far too similar to his Harry
Potter persona.
Felton claims he's not at all like the kid
that made him famous…
"To be honest, I'm very un-Malfoy like in
my day-to-day biddings"
However, in 2011's Rise of the Planet of the
Apes, he played a small part as Dodge Landon,
a cruel zoo security guard who tortures the
film's central sentient ape, Caesar.
"Take your stinking paw off me you damn dirty
ape."
Like Draco, the character is remarkable only
for his sniveling demeanor and the ease with
which audiences root against him.
Between this role and his villainous TV turn
on TNT's Murder In the First, he may not be
distancing himself from the role that made
him famous, which could make him seem a little
one-note to casting directors.
Indeed, even Radcliffe has had to work hard
to extricate himself from the world of broomsticks
and floo powder, taking roles that are far
off the mark of the Boy Who Lived.
By heading right back into an unlikable mini-baddie
role after Deathly Hallows, Felton may have
made a huge career misstep right from the
start.
Regaining confidence
Another surprising downside to the safety
of a long-lived role like Felton had in the
Harry Potter series is that the series' end
can feel a little like being thrown into the
ocean without a life vest.
The actor has admitted that returning to the
regular practice of auditioning for parts
to sustain a lifestyle, rather than just trying
to fill in the blanks between sequels, was
very difficult for him to adjust to.
He told the Daily Mail in 2011:
"I'm much more nervous in auditions now than
I was at 11.
You take a lot of hits before you get something
good.
The first few were heartbreaking."
The disappointment of being denied certain
roles was so disorienting for him, in fact,
that he considered walking away from the business
altogether, saying:
"I thought, 'I can't do this.'
They are cutthroat in America.
Before you've even started, someone's playing
on the BlackBerry.
You're reading your lines, physically convulsing,
and they just say 'Thank you.'
That means, 'Get lost.'
I did 19 auditions and got the 20th, for the
film The Apparition."
To make matters worse, that movie would mark
the start of a series of box office flops.
Missing box office magic
Although the Harry Potter series was a box
office phenomenon, Felton has still not proven
himself to be a bankable actor.
His small-time thriller pic The Apparition
failed to recoup its financiers' investment,
despite having both a Harry Potter star and
Twilight alum Ashley Greene leading the cast.
Since then, he's yet to appear in a film that
made any kind of impression at the ticket
booth.
Even movies that have been relatively well-received
by critics, like the regal biopic Belle and
A United Kingdom, featured him only in supporting
roles and brought in very little money during
their small theatrical runs.
Felton's not the only one of the Harry Potter
alums who has struggled to convince muggles
to see his movies, but being associated with
so many bombs likely isn't making his new
agent's job any easier.
Blond ambition
Considering his dismal box office streak,
Tom Felton's chances of nabbing a leading
movie role anytime soon seem low, but it might
not be a good idea to tell him that.
In fact, the actor's ambitions seem to be
unfettered, he not only wants another franchise,
but he wants one of the most iconic and long-lasting
of all time: Bond, James Bond.
He told Metro that playing the suave 007 agent
is an "unfulfilled career ambition" for him,
adding:
"I haven't landed James Bond yet.
Playing Bond or a Bond villain was why I wanted
to do movies in the first place."
Considering that may be the most coveted role
in all of Hollywood, his expectations may
be a bit lofty and unrealistic.
Time to turn it around
These days, Tom Felton does seem to be settling
in with a more low-key professional lifestyle.
In 2016, for example, he nabbed a recurring
role in the third season of The CW's The Flash,
and while the role didn't carry on to the
next season, it did help introduce him to
a new and different fanbase in the comics
community.
He was also cast in the little-seen, but ambitious
adaptation of William Shakespeare's Hamlet,
titled Ophelia, alongside some big names like
Daisy Ridley and Naomi Watts.
Neither project has put him on a new trajectory
for success yet, but they have helped Felton
stretch into new territory that might better
convince casting agents he's capable of doing
more than a bunch of Draco Malfoy impressions
in the future.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!